e giusto minchia di gioco inutile non
sono mai riuscita a vincere una [ __ ]
partita stavolta pinko mi sono rotto i
co riesci volte che lo porto sul canale
una volta mi fate vince la sto merda di
gioco non c'è giorno 2 giorno giorno due
sono partiti loro haka loro sono già
avanti io voglio farlo bene torniamo il
menù è anche un giorno salto tutto
dall'inizio alla fine frega niente
qualcuno che ha voglia di spiegarvi
perché è partito la giorno 2
completamente a caso vabbè vabbè si
ghazi allora abbiamo delle cose
manca la mappa però abbiamo la radio va
bene giorno 1 sem riuscite a chiudere la
botola un attimo prima esplosione va
bene sono tutti salvi
ok questo rifugio bene nessuno mangia
perché vi ha ammazzate gli schiaffi mary
jane oggi non ha dato problemi o forse
problemi non ho avuto il coraggio di
darle noia
ok andiamo avanti oggi siamo svegliati
con una strana sensazione era come se
qualcuno gli stesse osservando avremmo
potuto giurare che cosa si stesse
muovendo nell'ombra si è qualcos'altro
tra noi vive nel bunker al momento di
farli capire chi comanda
io direi di no perché non sprecherei gli
oggetti vediamo se ho fatto bene se a
quanto pare si sono ancora vivi
ah no mentre correvano da parte
all'altro cerca di qualcosa di mazzano
quel roditore pelose semplicemente
svanito nel nulla
uno dei nostri barato di cibo ha fatto
la stessa fine va a fan culo allora gli
stanno parlando di lanci di rifornimenti
e provviste il caso di uscire fuori dare
un'occhiata non ho la maschera antigas
da affanculo che sfiga
dai dai sono carico giorno 4 forza non
mangiate non bevete non vi tagliate i
capelli e la prima volta nella mia vita
che sono veramente così determinato a
finisco merda di gioco che vi giuro su
dio impossibile perché la prima parte in
game e il messicano
ma cos'è spagnolo messicano portoghese
reso il venus brin card e o questo o no
avendo come anni fa come le tre perché è
scritto in portoghese e poi divertito
paul estremi nudo sma como todomondo e
scoli alle terapie da alle tra ppq
sicuro direbbe è sempre meglio quando
tutto è tranquillo vabbè è tranquillo
tranquillo tende sembra far bene anche
se il mondo va in vacca la deriva 9
tanto dopo lo spagnolo non mi sarei più
stupito di nulla
meno male che non avete parlato tedesco
perché poteva essere un bel problema o
nessuno ancora mangiato niente nessuno
zero ed abbastanza forte vai cosa era
quello un topo piccoli legati alle cose
che vai collage a maicon lascia speriamo
che nessuno si ammali che li dobbiamo
tagliare un braccio ma vai con lascia a
posto hai perso lascia no
ok le nostre lattine sono salve la
credenza del rifugio era un po instabile
così abbiamo spostata per riposizionarle
così abbiamo scoperto una porta segreta
dove conduce non si sa ma lo scopriremo
vai con la torcia dai ragazzi dai
ragazzi dai ragazzi non vi fate sbranare
da un cammello mutante che sta nella
porta c'è una mappa che fortuna avere
quella torcia senza di esse non avremmo
visto il mucchio di vecchie mappe
impolvera che culo erano per la maggior
parte noiose carte di parchi nazionali e
simili ma ora di essere un utilissima
mappa per la città ok io sono questi
rumori vengono dalle fottute vengono
dalle fottute baretti li stanno facendo
impazzire e se fosse qualcosa che
striscia nel condotto d'areazione
rilassiamo ci facciamo un respiro
profondo dobbiamo distrarci
vai con la dama non credo che la dama si
usuri a usarla giusto vertici un po ci
ha fatto dimenticare di che si trattava
c'è qualcuno che passava da ok vai
accenni a radio capiamo quando le
radiazioni si abbassano e possiamo
uscire fuori
buone notizie il governo annunciato la
radio che evacueranno i sopravvissuti
della nostra zona dovremo aspettare un
altro po le successive istruzioni
saranno fornite nei prossimi giorni ok
ok sta bene ok ma tutti mi dai money
ultimi spedizione [ __ ]
aprite aprite cosa possa aprite tua
sorella apriamo era a torre delle 26
magari era un aiuto però non crede
scarlino prima silenzio finché il gruppo
all'esterno non se n'è andato ma ci ha
solo scritto aprite dai team dyt imi dai
team di cazzo dai team by cosa portare
fuori proiettili ascia
se puoi portare i proiettili non il
fucile a vuoi portare più cose allora
proietti e fucile dai dai zio dai zio se
muori e mi perdi il fucile i proiettili
ti giuro che ti ammazzo te lo giuro
logiche secondo fa vigenti e mi è andato
da fuori speriamo che se la cavi non so
cosa faremo senza di lui e
l'equipaggiamento e soprattutto per
l'equipaggiamento non per lui se timi
non è in grado di usare un fucile avrei
giocato a call of duty è la stessa cosa
dai dai ragazzi dai no no no no in casa
c'era scritto sbagliato cazzo non ho
letto cosa c'era scritto è infatti la
tipa si sta ammalando timi sei un
[ __ ] mito cosa hai fatto al fucile
hai tentato di dare in testa qualcuno
cerca tutto sopra mammut spiegami
durante la spedizione è stato
danneggiato come le munizioni che
avevano provato con noi non ci sono più
ops
diamine quella valigia ci piaceva
proprio beh ormai è persa e pasta e
basta hai trovato una bottiglia d'acqua
e basta quanti schiaffi vuoi in faccia
ho barattato un fucile dei proiettili e
una valigia per una bottiglia di pipita
snella domanda ragazzi ma secondo voi e
se mando il padre e muore il padre fuori
poi ho perso
secondo me no cioè spero vino più vicino
c'è un piccolo gruppo di sopravvissuti
piquet altro vecchietti dell'ospizio non
dovrebbe essere difficile prendere
qualche prevista in prestito la loro
qualcosa mi dice che quelli non sono
vecchietti dello sfizio però proviamoci
ce l'ho fatta oddio perché c'è una mano
cos'è se ora abbiamo più provvista per
qualche ragione non ci sentiamo molto
soddisfatti prove poveri vecchietti e io
credevo che fossero tutti hulk hogan da
una certa si si strappa una maglia bene
4 zuppe in culo al topo nuovo annuncio
radiofonico e l'esercito perlustreranno
in quartiere alla ricerca di
sopravvissuti ma hanno bisogno di segni
evidenti della presenza di persone
allora avete una guida da boy scout una
radio delle zuppe un miliardo e mezzo di
cosa e tu vuoi lasciare le carte che non
giovi e mi adora il succo di mele ma ora
dovrebbe avere un po d'acqua che cazzo
me ne frega che adoro il succo di mele
la ricaduta radioattiva è quasi
terminata ora dovrebbe esservi sicuro
piacere in superficie o timi non ha
detto nulla ma al suo ritorno quando era
fuori si e ferito una mano con il fil di
ferro o qualche altro metallo
arrugginito la ferita non abel aspetto
dobbiamo intervenire
vai canzone mi sa che forse questa non è
il massimo proviamo col kit dai però lo
usiamo forse era meglio tagliare il
braccio
un cazzo sbagliato da taglio alle
braccia porca eva perché ho usato quello
[ __ ] devo tagliare il braccio cosa
portare fuori porta lascia che ne so io
difenditi uomo ragazzi ho paura di
mandare lui perché ho paura che se muore
lui finisce il gioco non so perché
abbiamo giocato a nascondino la partita
più lunga è durata circa 10 secondi è
solo perché era andata via la luce per
qualche attimo bellissima ora di fare
qualcosa dunque un insegnante della
scuola locale ci è riuscito a salvare a
un gruppo di bambini a condurli in un
ufficio vicino proviamo usare le
provviste dei bambini cosa è successo
più 4 che culo dovevamo farlo ma sì se
ne frega dei bambini se torna al padre
perfetto dio esiste
orca merda del seti taglio al braccio
seri guarisci siamo mandare dolore sono
spedizione timi può farcela non vedo
l'ora di partire bravo team i veri di
portarci un'altra bottiglia del cazzo
cosa fa quella cosa che faceva con
lascia o semi se mi perdi lascia se mi
perdi madonna ammazzo ti ammazzo di
schiaffi già si è uscita una volta è
fatto un casino
torna tra ti taglio la testa dell'altro
che braccio dai kings dai timida ritimi
ti prego dai team si sei grande cosa ci
ha portato cosa ci ha portato il nostro
team delle provviste in più ci avrebbero
fatto molto comodo ma la nostra
spedizione non ha portato frutti
metti un po il braccio infetto sul
tavolo zio abbiamo giocato per andare
fuori by dolore scorri portati lascia se
portati lascia zia se non mi porti
niente non tornare o meglio torna per
portarci lascia e poi muori ragazzi
giorno 40 siamo arrivati al quarantesimo
risolvemmo brin car ancora basta dio
santo dove andata mai jane a porta
abbiamo portato le carte e morto quello
perché è morto ted era malato da troppo
tempo arca [ __ ] cosa ha portato
questa uno di insetticida e basta ok te
ne vai dolores portaci un cazzo di
di mazzo di carte che doveva andare
fuori mi ricordo più
dolores vai no ho sbagliato ma vadano
fuori collages a [ __ ] o io non sono
anche giocare al gioco dove si clicca è
da una vita che non faccia una scelta in
un videogioco che è che la rimpiango per
tutto il video dovevo tagliarli il
braccio esigenza è stancata ha gettato
lascia dietro di sé l'arma ormai del
tutto inutilizzabile mi posso sapere io
che problemi al cervello a questa
ragazza
l'altra volta mi butti le delle
provviste adesso mi butti lasciasi
[ __ ] fammi capire
servono sempre le carte per i militari
che non ho 6 dolores non torna con un
[ __ ] maledetto mazzo di carte abbiamo
perso trova videoregione una soluzione
perché usare quello spense tc da per
creare nuovi farmaci magari no
te dici che non c'ho le carte mio dio la
prima cosa che prendo la prossima volta
nel rifugio quando prima che esploda la
bomba sono le carte che mi servono delle
carte le carte per la radio mi prendi
per il culo perché se io adesso li do la
radio poi come faccio a e vabbè che ora
radio prendi sta cazzo di radio e come
come si sente militari adesso le carte
ma mi manca la radio dolores torna con
una radio ti prego dimmi che porti una
radio quanto ci fate che ha trovato un
mazzo di carte acqua sviluppa e
valigetta niente mazzo di carte
va bene avete ascoltato dieci volte di
fila che i militari arrivavano se
mettevate le carte
mettete ste cazzo di carte adesso non vi
serve la radio per saperlo lo sapete già
posso farvi una domanda ragazzi così mi
viene spontaneo la valigetta questo
posso portare anche il lucchetto a che
cazzo serve il lucchetto lucchetto a
cosa serve un lucchetto non ho capito lo
porto a te lo do noi da cosa dovrebbe
servirgli un lucchetto non so perché c'è
un lucchetto non ho idea
un gruppo di banditi alle porte questo
punto la tardi vi sono due arrendersi a
combattere nessun compromesso
se ci portano via qualcosa mi incazzo 55
oddio se si portano via lei va bene si
sono portati via mia figlia non è un
problema
gli amici sono primati invece in via ma
invece prendere i nostri previste hanno
afferrato mary jane guarda sono
contentissimo sono va bene prendetevi
mia moglie prendetevela quella [ __ ]
subito fine va bene non sono scontento
di questo finale va bene questo è
successo o no invece i prezzi tutti
hanno sferrato dolores perfetto contento
sono l'aveva destituito aveva resistito
per 58 giorni ragazzi ho resistito per
58 giorni quasi 2 mesi ke kazzo di gioco
eque non si può finire suo gioco
impossibile siete morti ma sono contento
sono solo con non solo meritavano di
essere salvati vabbè vabbè ai ragazzi
conclude episodio spero vi sia piaciuto
e salgo ci ho provato veramente in tutti
i modi ma a quanto pare se avete bisogno
di persone commento è un mi piace anche
i vari social che come loro tane
descrizione se non si fischia tv ci
vediamo il prossimo video sperando di
vincerlo porca eva da ragazzi